and we people email us questions and we
tried to give them advice oh great yeah
i could do five hours with you but i'm
not gonna do what whitney did
thank you right we're ending it already
yeah no we're doing this at closing bit
oh okay yeah
uh before that we actually i actually
have a patreon question uh from fatty
winn
marcus stated to be an atheist but as a
native of new orleans new orleans a
hotbed of spirits and creole religions
does mark believe in ghosts
and does he have any good ghost stories
i don't and i
look down upon anyone who does believe
in ghosts i think it's silly
uh-oh now here's i have a question i
think because i i've been amazing
it's too convenient oh there's a ghost
in here it's like well wouldn't there be
millions of ghosts
from all the people that died and this
ghost has just happened to be moving
[ __ ] around
suddenly i don't know well this
spiritual energy i think that's real
there's all this energy and and stuff
from dead people and other people who've
lived before us
i'm with you on that but the caspari
kind of oh did you ever see the movie
they live
no oh with the glasses yes yeah it's
been a while because rodney
roddy roddy piper was in a movie called
they live right
he puts on a pair of glasses and then he
can see
yeah all the stuff you're just not
wearing the glasses my friend
ah i don't i don't buy it it's no no i'm
just
perfect and here's the deal bro my
grandmother was in this bedroom and you
can feel her shut up
all the time it doesn't make sense yeah
yeah yeah
but you don't believe in god at all nah
i would i wish i did
i didn't i don't either so let me it's
hard because he's very much
a believer oh well that's good no it's
not they say believers are
happier healthy it's true i agree yeah
yeah
but here's and and i know my belief
right is tied in to the fear of dying
of course right because without it right
i would just be completely and utterly
petrified yeah all right so i have to
believe in something so i could just
move on with life
and conveniently if there is something
you believed yeah
you're right about that have you seen
the documentary um hands on a hard body
no it's basically this contest
in texas where um they get like what 20
people they start with like 50 people
it's a radio pro
so a radio a radio show come on down to
you know i mean phil's
car lot yeah and we're doing a contest
to get this brand new truck
and so they get 20 contestants they have
to
put their hand somewhere on the truck
and whoever
you know i mean oh i've heard their hand
off of it they get
disqualified yeah eliminated but the
types that they have on
the types of people that they have on
there like you could basically bobby and
i were betting on who we think would
last the longest yeah and i always put
my money on the religious freak
just because that belief in something
bigger really keeps them there longer
and that
woman remember she was speaking in
tongues yeah she was there for like
three days
yeah yeah yeah yeah hand on this truck
yeah for me it's like i have this yeah
that's a good point i just have this
fear of dying that makes sense do you
have a fear of dying of course
that's why i want to do so much before i
go
it feels like it makes your life longer
you're doing stuff you're not wasting it
we're only here for one blip that's why
these people get so complainy and
annoying and sad i'm like
this is it this is the this is the only
shot we got and you're just gonna [ __ ]
and moan on
yelp come on hug your kids go outside
get a hobby
yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah so what you're
saying
is is that that thought processes and
the what you what you believe
is why you become as successful as you
have
i mean yeah i think just go for it go
for everything
that's very that's a good you know what
buddy let me say
this to you thumbs up to you man hit me
hey yeah you as well
you come on i you know i
i i i that's a good message for our
listeners to hear
yeah go for it no matter what it is take
a shot and you could fail but at least
you went
yeah even if you're working in a cubicle
or enough marker sorry
not enough of it all right white man
take it over
to do the thing hey guys we got some big
papayas over here this week's unhelpful
advice is brought to you by
the big papayas over at patreon